first let me start by saying congrats on
the movie had a blast with it what does
it mean for both of you to realize that
this is gonna be like the first scary
movie a whole bunch of kids you're gonna
see in their lives
oh that's if so that would be amazing
it's not if so it's it's a hundred
percent yeah I'd be honored to give them
that experience yeah we call it a
gateway horror movie it's the equivalent
of a young adult book you know I think
is it's also it comes from a spirit that
is really it's fun and and creepy and
scary but it's ultimately the characters
have such a good heart and the movie has
a good heart
about it you know it's not is one of
those movies where you elbow each other
and talk to the screen you know talk a
little bit about the process of taking
the individual stories the ones that you
wanted to use for this movie and finding
that through a way to join them all
together well that started that started
before Andrea showed up we've started
with the group of writers and the
developing team and I said let's
everybody bring the stories that they
remember the most and it actually comes
down to 20 and then to 10 and then from
those 10 you match them with the
characters because the book reads but
you're afraid of an writes itself for
you you know which is an idea that came
from Pan's Labyrinth from the book of
crossroads that the girl has and and I
think that made it easy but each of us
lost a story or two that we loved you
know that we wanted in the movie but
didn't fit any of the characters talk a
little bit I'm very curious your
decision-making on when to use practical
and when to use CGI
I mean it's 90% practical I mean CGI is
mostly for enhancement and it's no I
mean it was this decision that was made
very early I mean I was like coming into
it thinking how we gonna do these
creatures and Gilmore immediately said
we're gonna do them for real we're gonna
create these creatures and that was
fantastic I mean the best the sculptors
I've known for each creature it's like
casting a movie you know Mike Hill is
great for this one Norman Cabrera you
know mike gillich shall be you match
like hessian this guy is great for days
this and they take it like animation
from beginning to end
yeah um he's known for what I call
collecting things so what did you manage
to take home from set versus what he
stole but I got one of the books
actually are you sure because he might
have taken that no you know it's funny I
never never keep anything from movies I
produce oh right yeah
in this case I'm I hope I can get a bust
of the bail lady just I love that
character but I didn't take anything
it's funny I realize it only now I'm
shocked that you he let you have the
book yes I listen ultimately I love
talking about the editing process cuz
it's the final rewrite so talk a little
bit about what happened you get in the
editing room what made you immediately
happy what made you nervous no I mean
it's always about you know it's it's
creating the flow of the movie that is
really that it's like it just flows and
that is like an abstract thing that you
don't really know until it's there and
you have to fight for it and fight for
it the set pieces work the scenes the
acting performances all work but then
it's about the flow and then Gilmour
came in in that process and really just
like okay look here now we're gonna do
room this and it just suddenly just
snapped into place and it was like it
was amazing to experience to see how
clearly he sees how sharp the movie can
get the way we we have a saying that you
can always get out eight minutes of any
cut any first cut for sure and that's
between friends you know they got phones
on the handle we do it easily but what
is beautiful about the way Andrew shoots
is the way he moves a camera so you have
to be very careful suggesting a cut but
when you see a card you say look dry it
and if it doesn't work we press undo and
it goes away
that's a beautiful in general editing
sure I'm curious II you must have done a
test screening or two on this movie what
did you learn test screening the movies
that in
the finished film did some tweaks at the
ending yeah you know we also went back
for a couple of days yeah we should I
mean that's the greatest thing I've
never done in a movies I need a rig but
I've done it on movies I produced where
you go let's go I can rich in a day or
two we did it on mama we did on this one
and it helps because you're financed
exactly I mean it's amazing how much our
clothes above a hand or a little senior
and over and over changed completely the
entire movie any little mosaic than your
needs completely I don't want to do
spoilers but I am curious you end the
film on like a bittersweet note yeah I
don't want to I mean I'd love to get a
specific but was it always gonna be that
did you make any changes or what was
your motivation for ending that way I
mean no I mean the motivation it's just
that we wanted to end on a kind of on a
high note
really we wanted to make sure that you
you've been through this process with
the characters that is so grueling and
they've lost so much and there is
something it has to be something
rewarding at the end and something lost
and some whatever
I mean the thing is when I remember
pitching mama with Andy and we said and
one of the characters the spoilers had
one of the characters goes away forever
that is basically and in this movie was
the same we say also and so those losses
are permanent the two things I was clear
about was period movie and this these
kids that go away they don't come back
from a luminous fall home we always knew
no no they're gone you know and that's
important
completely I'm about to run out of time
so I just have to ask you an individual
what was it about nightmare alley that
said I want to do this next and what can
you tease fans of yours about the
project well what it is and that book
was given to me in 1992 by Ron Perlman
you know and before iris although Tyrone
Power movie and I loved the book and
on my addition and that I've done with
Kim Morgan is not necessarily the entire
book is impossible it's a saga but there
are elements that are darker in the book
and it's the first chance I have in my
short film tied I wanted to do nor and I
wanted to do it was Horan or and now is
the first chance I have to do a really
underbelly of society type of movie and
and I think it's you know no
supernatural elements just straight
really dark story it will it be rated or
yes and all are but you know you have to
ask that because you know you never know
yeah I gotta go I have a million other
questions but I mean it seriously
congrats and especially you know all
these kids are gonna see this thing and
be totally terrified